almost everything that we say is
ultimately forgotten by the people who
listen and this is especially true when
you're standing in front of someone and
speaking you have been to conferences I
am sure where you sit through 6 seven
eight talks you finish the conference
you stop in the restroom on the way to
your car and by the time you pull into
the driveway almost everything that was
said throughout the entire day has now
been forgotten it's not because you're a
bad listener it's because the thing
things that people say are forgettable
it's like they want to be forgotten they
speak in sentences instead of speaking
in stories everything you say will be
forgotten unless you give people a
reason to remember what you
said my wife and I were at a conference
about a year ago an educational
conference Alicia is a kindergarten
teacher I'm a fifth grade teacher we
were all in on this conference we
actually went to it hoping to learn
something
the first Speaker of the day was a man
who took the stage holding an old 1980s
metal lunchbox he put it on a stool and
he began to tell a story he told a story
about how his parents were first
generation Americans with almost no
money they were struggling to put food
on the table and yet every year at the
beginning of the school year they always
went out and bought their son a brand
new lunchbox The Lunchbox the one that
is required to be cool and if if you
grew up in the
1980s you know exactly what I'm talking
about there were the kids who had the
right lunch boxes for me it was kiss or
the Muppet Show or were the kids who had
the wrong lunchboxes and the right
lunchbox was Social Capital it meant
access to cool kids these parents who
had no money who could barely put food
on the table every single September went
out and made sure that their son had The
Lunchbox he needed so that he could find
friends and have the social capital
required to get through the school day
he told us that story he told us the
enormous amount of effort his parents
went through to give him opportunities
that they never had and then he told us
to make sure that when kids walk into
our classrooms every day we remember and
we honor the sacrifices of the parents
who have sent those kids to our schools
the sacrifices that we often don't see
but must know our happening I will never
forget that story and I will never
forget that message it is in my heart in
my mind forever and it's simply because
that man told a story he told a story
that was filled with humor and heart he
showed us a lunchbox he spoke about his
parents he made me believe in everything
he said and because he told me a story I
can remember it today the last speaker
of the day served the keyot not speaker
of the day took the stage and did a
fantastic job he spoke in perfectly
constructed sentences he delivered those
sentences brilliantly he was eloquent he
was stylish he was
perfect after the conference was over I
immediately turned to Alicia and said
what' you think now in addition to being
a kindergarten teacher Alicia is also
the producer of our show and the MC of
our show and so she said said well that
first Speaker I'm never for going to get
his story and I agreed it was a story
and it touched her heart too and then I
said what' you think about the last
speaker and she said he was great and I
said yeah he was what did he say now it
was like 2 minutes after he had finished
speaking and I turned to a woman who is
an educator and someone who is invested
in public speaking and storytelling and
I said what do he say and she said huh
I don't really know I said yeah you
already forgot it didn't you and she
said I did I had forgotten it too
why he didn't tell a story he assembled
lovely sentences in a perfect order and
he spoke them perfectly and they were
all forgotten if you don't land images
in someone's mind if you don't land a
story in someone's heart if you don't
touch them emotionally while you're
speaking you will be forgotten you will
be forgotten 2 minutes after you're done
speaking by two people who are invested
fully in what you're doing and how
you're doing it that is exactly what
happened at that educational conference
and that's exactly what happens every
single day in business people stand on
stages in boardrooms they sit at
conference tables they conduct all hands
and everything that comes out of their
mouth is forgotten unless it's told with
a story unless it lands images in the
hearts and minds of the
audience I'm never going to forget that
man with his lunchbox and I don't think
you're going to forget it either you
didn't even hear the guy speak I
reported on a story that someone told
and I suspect you're going to remember
it for a long time because it's a story
you have a choice you can be forgettable
by lining up lovely sentences or you can
tell a story and be remembered for a
long time remember almost everything
people say in this world today is
forgotten unless you give them a reason
to remember storytelling will give them
a reason to remember